brexit everyone has their own opinion
about whether it's illegal to stay each
side often throws about big numbers that
prove their points but as the famous
politician Benjamin Disraeli reportedly
says there are lies damned lies and
statistics so what do the numbers mean
and who's right
Bloomberg's taken alone the debate is
really focused on three key issues trade
the membership fee and immigration the
latter is the most contentious 2.7
million people are predicted to arrive
in the country by 2030 and the leave
campaign say immigration is putting
pressure on the job market and welfare
system the stronger in campaign say the
net inflow of migrants to the UK will
slow official figures suggest a drop in
net migration to 185 thousand in 2021
from over 300,000 in 2015
funnily enough both say the same thing
the number of migrants will go up if
Britain stays what's lacking in those
numbers is context it's true the number
of EU immigrants moving to the UK has
increased recently just over half came
from the EU in 2015 but if you look back
over the past 25 years you'll see the
non EU migrants still account the
majority of immigration to the UK a vote
to leave could curb migration but it's
important to know that any attempt to
renegotiate full access to the single
market would require the UK to accept
free movement of labour the second topic
is the membership fee leave say being a
member of the EU cost Britain 350
million pounds every single week or 18
billion pounds a year the remain side
acknowledged that figure but say it
doesn't take into account what Britain
gets back if they're taken into account
the annual sum reduces to just over 8
billion pounds that's 0.4 percent of GDP
or about 35 pence per person per day
finally there's trade 44 percent of
exports go to the EU that's big but the
share has been falling as exports to
other economies have risen remain say
it's too big a market for Britain to
walk away from lycée being freed from
the EU will allow Britain to take
advantage of the fast-growing markets
outside of Europe
Bloomberg intelligence have a model
it looks complicated it is complicated
but if you break it down you can see
this part that gives you the estimate
that trade between the UK and other
members of the single market is 10%
higher than with similar countries
outside the EU that translates into the
level of GDP being about two percent
higher than it would have been had
Britain remained outside the European
Union that doesn't mean Brits will wake
up on the 24th of June 2% poor if they
vote to leave but it does mean the
stakes are high in any trade deal
negotiations